hey guys welcome to a new video on code
tech and tutorials today i figured i
would uh
check out the new unreal engine 5 and uh
just kind of give my
opinion on it so we're just going to
watch
the video from like four days ago i know
i'm a little behind on this but
uh since i'm making a game uh engine
and pretty much trying to do all this
stuff uh by hand by code
it'd probably be a good one to react to
because why not so let's have a let's
have a look
here we go hi i'm chance ivey
senior technical designer at epic games
and i'm galen davis producer and
evangelist for quicksilver at epic games
wait did he just say producer and
evangelist for qixel
all right sounds weird but all right
let's go this summer we revealed the
first look at what's coming in unreal
engine 5
the next generation of our real-time
technology and our demo lumen in the
land of nanite
since then the engine team has been
working hard on preparing the tools
and technology for creators around the
world to get their hands on so that they
can explore the new features and provide
us with feedback now just a few months
ago we assembled a small team of
developers to see what they could build
using these new features the result is a
new practical sample project
called valley of the ancient today we're
excited to give you the very first
hands-on look at some of the new tools
and workflows that we use to build it
now we've got a lot to get to so let's
get started
wait this looks a lot like their old
demo right they
what they put one out like a year ago
that was
i don't know whatever let's just watch
okay that lighting's nice
very nice look how it goes over the
rocks and everything
pretty good when setting out to make our
demo we wanted to push the bounce oh
whoa
look right there okay let me move my cam
there's something weird going on right
right here watch right there i think
they got a little
bug in their lighting code
boundaries what's possible with let's
back that up again
okay look right here getting out to make
our demo
no we wanted to push the boundaries of
what's possible it's like flickering
oddly
um kind of surprised they left that in
that soon but
all right let's continue
i've already found a problem it's a
small problem
like it's you know but for how big
they're hyping this you would expect to
see like no glitches
we just already saw one right there
right there i don't know if you guys
could see the pointer on youtube it's
going to be small but right there just
watching we have to make our demo we
wanted to push the boundaries of what's
possible
that weird flickering i don't think it's
supposed to be doing that
today while targeting next-gen hardware
specifications
here are sequences running in real time
on placement okay that was nice that was
super nice
i'm gonna point something out i don't
know if you can tell this but you can
like
see the shimmer of the heat from the
desert in this area or the sun
like the mirage effect a little bit
i don't know if you'll be able to tell
on my recapture but that's that's
sequence is running in real time on
playstation 5 and xbox series x
fire looks really nice
like i know being nitpicky with the
light on the one thing but everything
else so far is looking
like perfect it's hard to even tell
that it's not real the only thing that
gave it away was that light
that i pointed out okay welcome to the
brand new ui in unreal engine 5.
brand new well a lot of the same
features whoa
okay so they got these just sidebars a
lot cleaner looking there's a bottom you
can't really tell because
you've come to know when you before are
still present in the new ui
we've added several new systems that put
you at the center of the experience
for example the content browser can now
be accessed like a drawer using hotkeys
very nice i like that i like that it
just collapses
allowing you to keep a clean workspace
while still having access to all the
content that you need
we can also collapse and restore editor
tabs to and from the sidebar
maximizing the viewport experience and
you're going to see a lot more of the ui
as we get further into this presentation
that's pretty cool this is a lot like um
it's kind of like how visual studio can
collapse things on the side and stuff
i think they're just using that which is
fine so far i don't know
this feature or this uh interface looks
a little better i think
i think it's an improvement but we can't
wait for you to get your hands on it
now one of the main features of unreal
engine 5 is nanite
our virtualized micro polygon geometry
system that free
danai our virtualized micro polygon art
is to create as much
detail as the eye can see whoa i mean it
looks good
but let's hear more virtualized geometry
supports orders of magnitude more
triangles without compromising speed
and replaces the traditional system of
mesh lods
handling all detail transitions
seamlessly without
replacing the traditional system of mesh
lods that's a pretty big deal because i
don't think that's really been done
in a while and lods are kind of a
problem in case you haven't noticed
like it's really laggy to run around on
most games
it's not too bad but it's also like
questionable sometimes like okay that's
a little glitchy
i think most big games will glitch a
little bit
when you're running around in the world
like let's think about pubg
how long has that had like little
hiccups in the frames forever
so maybe they need to use this new
system
but like every games like that it seems
like any big game
so if this can get rid of the old lod
frame hiccups while things and textures
are loading
it can make a big difference without any
additional setup
in other words nanites lets the artist
create while the engine does the work
and you don't even have to do anything
it just kind of does it that's pretty
cool
the engine does the work right switching
to this nanite visualization you can see
individual
triangles rendered out as different
colors here in the viewport and because
the geometry is now virtualized you can
feel free to place assets like these all
throughout your scene to fill out a
massive player space
wow that looks sweet using this debug
view
you can see individual instances
represented by different colors from
swatch to swatch
okay individual instances
i still quite understand how it works
but
like how do you render that many
triangles on demand
i don't know i'd like to see like the
technology behind i know they gave it
like a flashing name of
nanite or whatever but that's just a
name like
still curious about the technology each
instance in this environment contains
around one
okay wait
okay i don't know if this is his mouse
or something but there's a little
flickered gold on right
there opens the door to more dynamic
worlds and immersive gameplay
lumen is our fully dynamic real-time
global illumination solution
that immediately reacts to scene and
light change
doesn't unreal already have real-time
lighting i know you generally
bake your lighting but uh i thought they
already had real-time lighting
so i guess they're just improving it and
calling this next version lumen
or is this like a complete overhaul that
i'm not sure
let's continue making for more
believable experiences
and the gi hooks in directly with our
time of day settings allowing for true
physically based setups for
photorealistic environments
the mega scans library has meticulously
calibrated physically based services and
objects in the thousands of assets as of
today and the assets that were
highlighted here
show just how powerful it is to have
nanite and lumen working in tandem
well okay they got dust clouds going on
and the lighting looks
great here yeah this is very realistic
looking like this is hard to tell that
it's even
digital you know it's like that good
also thanks to the new sky atmosphere
system it is incredibly simple to
quickly simulate
realistic time of day i love the sky
atmosphere system when i'm an unreal i
play with that in every scene pretty
much
it's great let me know if you want
tutorials on unreal i've been playing
with
a bunch recently carefully art direct
volumetric clouds
and make modifications to things like
atmospherics sun position
and fog and for this example we wanted a
fully dynamic scene
no light baking and realistic
interpolation between the different
times of day
of course when in development having
access to high quality content that's
easy to use
helps you iterate quickly and saves lots
of time that can be better spent
elsewhere on your project
with quicksole now being a part of the
epic games family we've made the full
mega scans library
free and open for all unreal engine
users
that's pretty cool look they have a
random cucumber over here
all right bridge our online browser for
megascans assets has historically
functioned as a standalone application
for quickly exporting assets in bulk
directly into the engine
albeit separate from unreal today we're
happy to announce that bridge is now
natively integrated directly into the
engine ui
that's pretty cool that they're natively
integrating it so
are they going to pull them down via the
web or is it going to have you
pre-download
or only i guess it's probably only going
to download what you select but it's
still going to have to download
all the pictures i'm just kind of uh
wondering about how this is going to
affect the
performance of like the engine starting
up and stuff
now you can simply drag and drop assets
directly into your scene
for a more intuitive and connected
experience and simply log in with your
epic id gives you immediate access to
thousands of assets to use for free
in your unreal engine projects this is
cool
and all i love free assets
i guess i shouldn't complain because
they're free assets but i just feel like
we're gonna see
a bunch you know how like there's so
many games out there that just reuse the
same assets
there's nothing wrong with that if you
can get away with it but when you're
like a gamer
and you keep seeing the same assets with
different games
it's a little awkward so
i don't know i guess you can take that
for what you will but
just not the biggest fan of reusing
assets too much i like things to be
original
but that's just me
and also like how much work would it be
to recreate these i get it yeah reused
assets
we are constantly looking to enhance the
value of the mega megaskanes library
and today we're excited to announce that
we're adding a brand new asset type
called mega assemblies
because simplified assemblies are the
natural next step for us in removing
even more barriers for artists in
crafting their worlds
by combining existing assets from the
mega scans library
our artists are pre-assembling elements
that can be quickly accessed and
leveraged to populate your scenes
using the moab set let's add an assembly
to our scene
and just like that we were able to
quickly change the composition
of this area in our map whoa okay that's
super cool
but like even the rocks are falling
like that's just part of the asset that
there's no way
with you they had to do something i
don't know i'm just that's
just seems weird i've never like brought
in a rock or a cliff and had like it
start crumbling some
that seemed is that real we were able to
or did they do some stuff they add some
more effects on top of just dropping the
acid in
quickly change the composition of this
area in our map
because i i find it hard to believe that
that's just natively part of the
asset that crumbling effect but it kind
of gives you the impression that this
does look cool though it looks super
cool so
good job showed off with ue5
we are reimagining what collaboration
looks like for teams and projects of all
sizes
a common challenge when collaborating on
large worlds is deciding how to
structure map content
so that everyone on the team can easily
work without asset contention
while also avoiding painful merch
conflicts
i guess that's only for big teams i
think most people watch my channel are
like a little indie devs so they
probably like
uh i i can't find anyone to work on my
project with me
but i don't know again let's see what
their new system for working
on the team is maybe maybe we can
actually get some people together i
would love to do like a
channel project or something that anyone
could work on i think that'd be super
cool
called world partition makes traditional
world-building workflows obsolete
changing the way that we think about map
files rather than requiring artists to
build out
map content as a series of streaming
levels world partition allows teams to
think of a single map as one large world
that gets broken down automatically into
many smaller
streamable cells on a grid oh that is
super cool i really like that
so i really like the the mapping and
gridding system or what is it it's the
uh
i don't know the whole mesh world
builder thing the thing's fun it looks
like they're just completely redoing
that and now you can
have partitions of it that's super cool
i hope this is like functions like i
think it's going to function
these it's like you just i'll load a
scene and it'll be
giant and it'll take forever and tons of
stuff but usually you're only working on
like one
small area of the scene at a time you're
not like
working on the whole world once you're
working on like a little town or
something
so this is this is a super cool feature
i hope it's not like super buggy though
it looks like everything looks good when
they're showing it off here
so it's probably about ready cells can
be selectively loaded or unloaded in the
editor to save on edit time resources
allowing artists to only load up the
sections of the map that they need
on top of that changes to actors in a
world partition map
are tracked at the actor level not the
map level
this one file per actor approach
empowers different team members to work
on different actors in the same map
without having to worry about their
changes getting clobbered and emerge
or having to revert to get someone
else's edits
now wait one file per actor i'm not sure
i fully understand
what they said there the level not the
map
level changes to actors in a world
partition map are tracked at the actor
level
tracked at the actor level
not the map level not the map wait what
i i that doesn't make any sense to me
like you're editing the map
it doesn't change the map it changes the
actor what actor
just the grass are they talking about
the little grass
asset being an actor and that's the only
thing that changes enough
i'm confused by that i don't know what
they mean this one file per actor
approach
empowers different team members to work
on different actors in the same map
without having to worry about their
changes getting clobbered and emerge
or having to revert to get someone
else's edits
okay well that all sounds good but i
still don't quite understand what they
mean i don't know feel free to leave a
comment in time stamps if
if you think you know some of these that
i'm like
i don't know exactly what that means
sounds good
sounds really good but what do you know
all right let's continue
now this approach means you could have
artists lighting set dressing
and reworking the landscape
simultaneously all within the same
virtual space
ah here we go managing this much content
at runtime
typically requires a ton of thought
about how to stream relevant content in
and out to stay inside performance
budgets
fortunately world partition handles that
as well at runtime
only the cells in a user-defined radius
from our player are loaded
and well that's super cool
okay but that's kind of expected i mean
that's about
is that about the same as load on demand
except now it's just loading
by partition isn't this what like
minecraft does already
or is this different
and as we move new cells are streamed in
while cells no longer needed
are replaced by their lower resolution
hierarchical level of detail
or h-slot version and since all products
wait i thought they were getting rid of
lod but they just said
the old versions okay so the ones i
already passed over
are getting replaced by h law diversions
what does that mean
objects have different requirements the
cell size and loading radius are fully
configurable
to match each project's content
streaming needs
another feature that comes along with
world partition is data layers
data layers are a way to categorize map
assets and collectively enable or
disable them when you want to alter the
state of the world
working in data layers a separate group
of artists was able to assemble a
mythical reimagination
well okay this is just crazy right here
this is super cool though
of the environment with more interactive
elements for our demo
you could just completely morph a world
on the fly
like that
at runtime we can swap between these two
modes streaming thousands of actors in
and out
and enter into the dark world let's see
this in action as we go back to chance
thanks galen many runtime and
interactive frameworks in unreal engine
are getting significant updates in ue5
cool that's pretty nice looking so this
must be the alternative dark world
which is now going to go run around in
wow i do wonder also about the quality
of the hardware
one thing we've added for animation like
what uh
what are they running on they're
probably on like mac specs but like most
people
aren't running a max spec computer so
just curious how like
mid-range computers are going to hold up
and stuff
but just to be clear though if you're
developing
high-end aaa games on unreal
you probably want a computer that's
about maxed out a low or a mid-range one
that's just
it's not going to cut it so
just just fyi and is an experimental new
full-body ik solver which is designed to
give you better results with less work
here you can see it in action as the rig
for our player character
echo corrects itself to adjust for
variations on the ground below her
well auto corrects here i am trying to
get
uh animations working on opengl at a
base level and these guys are like
having them modify to the meshes
in the world it's like a whole other
level so they've
clearly put a ton of work in this
animations are hard
to get programmed perfectly and right to
have them like
be able to morph to the world live like
this with footsteps on the ground that
is
that's really impressive i'm already
really impressed by this feature
it's deterministic reliable and around
10 times faster than before
i'm actually impressed by like all these
features i'm just being a little
critical this
this video to build and maintain more
scalable gameplay systems we've also
added a new framework called game
feature plugins that will allow you to
build and ship game content in a more
modular way
wait game feature plugins to ship
content
what kind of content like dlc
or original content or just updates to
your game
let's find out i'm curious feature
plugins numerous core gameplay features
can be built in parallel with better
encapsulation and finer content
organization
game feature plugins allow developers to
add activation instructions to extend
base game functionality
register new input actions for players
and interface with other frameworks such
as animation
oh okay i see so they just
allow you to do all sorts of things
including button
presses for your character okay i guess
you know we already see that
in like engines some
but they're just building the whole
system based around it
so this looks this is pretty cool
when we shipped it into the dark world
we also activated a new game feature to
give echo a brand new attack ability
all of the assets and logic needed for
the ability including new animations
input controls blueprint code vfx and
audio
are contained inside this plugin and
core game classes have no idea that
these assets exist
until we activate it we've also added a
feature called animation motion warping
which allows you to manipulate root
motion animations to adapt them to the
world
echo's vault animation was authored to
the specific dimensions of this rubble
that looked a little weird not gonna lie
all right it's
i mean given that it adapts on the fly
to things it's like super cool but
authored to the specific dimensions of
this rubble this looks
wonky a little bit like that right there
is a bit of a shift
jump not too bad but that part right
there looked
floaty and i know i'm being super
critical like that
to be able to dynamically do something
like that on the fly is
really hard and a lot of work so i'm not
i'm not saying that it's bad i'm just
saying that
it's pretty obvious that we're breaking
reality there that's like that's not how
a person would vault over that thing you
know
leveraging motion warping we were able
to add notify states in the vault
animation asset that can react to
transform data passed in via blueprints
this allowed us to reuse the same
animation to vault over other assets of
different dimensions
like these pieces of debris by sending
information about their size into the
motion warping system
okay so it just sends the information
before triggering the vaulting animation
a blueprint okay let's see grip
determines her rotation
how high up she jumps how far she needs
to move to get to the other side
and wear her feet it's pretty cool i
just don't like that last jump that last
jump seemed a little awkward and the
volt up seems a little awkward it just
feels floaty it feels like
it doesn't feel like she's using a jump
or
pushing off the geometry it just feels
like she's floating
so i don't know i feel like maybe the
animation just needs a little bit of
work but it's still not bad it's still
it's still super cool and super awesome
motion warping then adapts the root
motion of the vault animation to match
this data
also for the rift interact animation we
use motion warping to place echo in the
perfect position in order to ensure her
hand would always touch the rift
so on the topic of animation unreal
engine 5 also includes our
in editor rigging tool control rig
control rig all right
whoa what do we got here
regular raid boss coming at you
all right how is this one lady gonna
take down this
massive behemoth of a thing
meet the ancient a film quality creature
imagined and built by our friends at the
aaron sims creative company
this thing is so cool looking we
partnered with aaron sims and his group
of talented artists to concept the dark
world
and to bring it to life through an
enormous mythical adversary
so what is is this just like a textured
bulb that's see-through with some
fire inside of it has like a little
effect
i don't know i'm just kind of thinking
how they made this without working too
hard you know
it's pretty interesting now every single
animation for the ancient was authored
holy and engine by the aaron sims
created
okay you can author an engine now
nice using control rig and sequencer our
linear cinematic animation tool
also just to push the boundaries a bit
they even built it out of a collection
of nanite meshes totaling over 50
million triangles attached directly to
the skeleton
wow control rig was designed to 50
million triangles
artists close to their creations without
having to bounce back and forth between
software packages
allowing them to quickly iterate all
inside unreal
while imagining the battle between echo
and the ancient we wanted to give the
creature a heavy laser attack that echo
would have to avoid
we needed it to track echo's location in
the arena and fire a slow sweeping blast
towards her
okay that's cool so targets her makes a
sweeping blast
does the animation hold on i want to see
something here
i can't really see it here but i was
trying to check what kind of damage it
was doing to the ground like was it
pteromorphing the ground is it lasered
because how next level would that be but
it looks like
i can't really tell it's definitely a
lot of sparks there
but is there is there like a little
crater there now
there might be i don't know we'll see
taking advantage of the full body ik
solver mentioned earlier
we were able to influence the direction
and distance the ancient reaches out
during the firing animation based on
where echo is in the scene
let's see the results here is what the
base firing animation looks like
okay so here it is a base fire animation
and then they just use some
modifications to change a little bit
kind of like they do with the vault
again with the full body ik post process
layers enabled
and our info about echo passed into
control rig
with full body ik and control rig
designers and artists can now author
fully dynamic animations that react to
gameplay without having to build complex
animation state machines composed of
numerous animation assets
okay that's really cool because yeah
that's one of the problems with
animations is you're stuck
with this set of animations that you
built and nothing else but
being able to make them dynamic
that's a a little bit next level i don't
know if that's already done at all in
any engines but
that's a really cool feature to have in
an engine
in unreal engine 5 we've completely
overhauled the audio engine
centered around metasounds completely
overhauled the audio engine
centered around medicine okay asset type
used for every sound effect in our demo
metasounds bring the power and
flexibility found in material editors to
audio creation
providing fine control for authoring
procedural game audio
look at all this stuff wave player add
envelope
wave player okay so you're just able to
do all sorts of effects
and this isn't anything too new but
being able to have like a big workflow
of it an
engine is pretty cool with full audio
synthesis capabilities and a rich audio
function library
meta sounds give unprecedented control
over sound effects and runtime
applications
controller runtime cool using metasounds
we built the ancients laser attack out
of a combination of sound samples and
synthesized audio
wow so that wasn't just an effect that
was like
an effect with effects on it well
let's briefly break down how it was set
up using the stereo mixer
let's isolate and play just the
synthesized charge sound
[Music]
okay
well so they have a combination of five
different sounds in that beam okay
that's
that's crazy but cool this effect is
made by using a handful of sound wave
generators and multiple modulation
widgets
now let's mix back in our sound samples
to hear the final result again
[Music]
all right let's take down the ancient
there's this attack
one shot where are your hit points now
okay two shot maybe
it still seemed way too easy to take out
this big guy just two shots
two little blasts i know they're just
the demo okay
but just imagine getting to like the
last boss and some big raid
and it just it goes down this easy
still cool demo not not hating on it
obviously they don't want to sit here
and shoot like a million times but
i'd like to see more dynamic hits of
what it's like to
like hit it in the arm and stuff does it
does it move
or is it like specifically designed only
to be hit in those two spots i don't
know
now everything we've been showing you in
today's demo focuses on some of the new
features in ue5 but many of your
favorite ue4 features such as niagara
particles and visual effects
chaos physics blueprint visual scripting
and more
have also received numerous updates in
unreal engine 5.
geez unreal 5. this is going to be good
i can't wait to get my hands on this let
me know what you guys think are you
excited about unreal engine 5
uh let me know your opinions down below
and also
one like equals one hour of me
streaming development yeah that's
that's right plus all your ue4 projects
can be upgraded to ue5
so you won't have to worry about forward
compatibility for what you're working on
now
nice you can just upgrade them okay
that's always a concern because i have
a project in unreal four
but if you can just upgrade and be like
all right no
change is necessary that's super cool
here at epic we are passionate about
building great tools and new technology
and a big part of our excitement is
being able to bring you the developer
community
on the journey with us so today we're
making an early access build of unreal
engine 5
freely available on the epic games
launcher and the unreal engine github
so you can explore and test out these
tools yourself to get an early look at
what's coming later in the full release
of ue 5.0
also we're releasing the project source
for value of the ancient
so you can check out how we use these
features to build everything you've seen
in today's demon
the releasing the source and the engine
so we can go play with this
let me know guys do you want to see this
see me play around with this
project where we go and where
let's see here we want to look for
unreal engine
where's 25 here it is
yeah it's just right on the front page
very nice
all right well i'll mess with that after
this video but it's up there it's right
on the front page
uh what have i done okay here we go
we've got a series of deep dive
conversations on these topics lined up
for
inside unreal our official weekly live
stream where
you can hear from the engine dev team
and ask your questions
now i think they already did this live
stream i'm a little late to the party
here
now these are still the early days of
ue5 and you can expect
more news and features to be announced
as we move closer to a production-ready
release
targeting early 2022. follow the unreal
engine social channels for more
information
okay very cool very cool let me just
back up because yeah here's the inside i
think they already did
the live presentation this is like a two
hour thing
live stream
welcome to unreal engine 5 early access
insight unreal so this is like a whole
thing
where they it looks like kind of a panel
for the most part they're just talking a
lot
it's like two hours a great thing to
listen to
on your way to work i don't know it's
that's pretty cool all right and here i
am copying the shirt
that's not my intention i really did
want to like give my opinion on this i
actually haven't
watched this video yet so don't worry
sure no i'll eventually watch your video
just uh yeah i really wanted to get this
reaction
so uh we'll see you guys in the next one
peace out